grueling auditions Fierce competition
from the world's biggest stars and an
endorsement from Denzel Washington these
facts about boslerman's Elvis will make
your jaw drop
Austin Butler hadn't given much thought
to playing one of the world's most
iconic figures in music before 2018.
however in Elvis Christmas song sparked
something in him as he told deadline I
never heard it before in my life but in
the month prior to hearing about baz
making the film an Elvis Christmas song
was on the radio and I was kind of just
goofing around singing along to it and
my friend said you've got to play Elvis
that friend was actually his
then-girlfriend Vanessa Hudgins and she
even suggested that Butler should try to
get the rights to write an Elvis biopic
according to Butler Hudgins brought up
the idea again a few weeks later while
he was playing the piano but he
dismissed the suggestion a week later
his agent told him about baslerman's
movie and Butler recalled to deadline
well immediately I got chills because of
the synchronicity of it all I thought I
got to just give it everything I got
Austin Butler underwent a long audition
process for Elvis which mostly consisted
of him reading the script and singing
for baslerman over and over again as he
admitted on the Kelly Clarkson show we
ended up doing that for five months what
is unlike any audition
before that grueling process began
Butler said the director a self tape of
himself playing the piano and singing
Unchained Melody prior to filming the
tape Butler discovered that Elvis's mom
died when the Superstar was just 23
years old Butler was the same age when
he lost his mom too which of course
influenced his performance the former
Disney Channel star told deadline I
ended up filming this tape that came out
of a nightmare that my mom was dying
again it was an emotion of such deep
pain it kind of Stripped Away the icon
of him or the caricature of him and it
just made him so human the video was raw
and emotional and Lerman told variety
that he was blown away by Butler's
performance
Austin Butler faced some Fierce
competition for the role of Elvis before
he was officially in the running
baslerman screen tested many other
actors and singers including Harry
Styles in fact Styles was reportedly one
of the Front Runners for the role before
Butler entered the ring during an
interview on Howard Stern's Sirius XM
show styles explained Elvis was probably
the first person I knew besides my
family when I was a kid for that reason
there was something incredibly sacred
surrounding him so I thought I should
try to get the part unfortunately there
was one major problem with casting the
former One Direction singer director
Lerman explained to people the real
issue with Harry is he's Harry Styles
he's already an icon meanwhile the
casting agent for Elvis told variety
that there were other names in the mix
too firstly Miles Teller who showed off
his musical chops by singing The Rock
and Roll hit Great Balls of Fire in Top
Gun Maverick was up for the part of
Elvis additionally West Side Story star
Ansel Elgort was reportedly on lerman's
radar for the part ultimately though
Butler beat them all well I just felt so
privileged to get to go on that Journey
with baz it was it was just the time of
my life I felt so happy
deadline Austin Butler revealed that
from the moment he heard about the movie
he started prepping for his
five-month-long audition process as
though he'd already gotten the role
acting like he was already making the
movie was clearly a tactic that worked
for the actor it also helped that Denzel
Washington put in a good word for the
young actor with whom he'd worked on a
2018 Broadway production of Eugene
O'Neill's the Iceman Cometh in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
Lerman recalled I got a call from Denzel
Washington who gave me a cold call I did
not know Denzel and he said I've just
worked with this guy on stage I've never
seen a work ethic like it and I'm like
okay I must see him and he says you're
about to meet an actor I've been on
stage with
it seems that Butler lived up to
Washington's recommendation as he did
nothing but live as Elvis for the two
years it took to film The biopic during
a press conference at the Cannes Film
Festival Butler admitted I basically put
the rest of my life on pause for two
years and I just absorbed everything
that I possibly could and I just went
down the rabbit hole of obsession
Elvis began pre-production in 2019 after
casting the film's Stars preparations
were being made to begin filming in
Australia in March 2020 however
everything came to a grinding halt when
star Tom Hanks and his wife Rita Wilson
tested positive for covet 19. thankfully
the couple's symptoms weren't too severe
and they were able to return to the
United States two weeks later like most
people Lerman didn't anticipate the
longevity of the pandemic while Hanks
and Wilson weren't quarantine and any
cast and crew members who had been in
contact with them were isolating he
tweeted we're not even taking our sets
down simply locking up the creative
space over the next few days while no
other members of the cast or crew became
infected with covid-19 it was several
months before everyone was able to
return to set filming officially began
on September 23 2020. at the time Lerman
said in a statement to deadline we're
back to as Elvis liked to say taking
care of business it is a real privilege
in this unprecedented global moment that
Tom Hanks has been able to return to
Australia to join Austin Butler and all
of our extraordinary cast and crew to
commence production on Elvis Butler
later confirmed to GQ that filming
finished in March 2021
despite telling director bazlerman that
he didn't really sing during one of his
auditions Austin Butler ended up
performing some of the king's iconic
songs in Elvis according to deadline
Lerman planned to have a voice
impersonator take over vocals for
Elvis's younger years because he wasn't
able to use the original recordings for
copyright reasons however he was
completely moved by Butler's abilities
telling deadline I mean when you hear
him sing it's crazy you cannot believe
it's spine tingling we just started
riffing and hours would go by as the
movie progressed Lerman decided to blend
Butler's voice with the king's original
music to show how his voice changed over
the years composer Elliot wheeler told
collider we ended up slicing parts of
Austin's performance we used a lot of
the breaths Grunts and body movements
that are Austin and we'd switch back to
Elvis there's people out there who say
that ever since I played Elvis my voice
has changed
despite its upbeat musical numbers Elvis
certainly couldn't be called a
light-hearted feature the film makes it
clear from the start that Elvis Presley
didn't have it easy growing up for
instance Elvis had a big hole in his
heart that came from losing his twin
brother at Birth he also dealt with the
shame of his father going to jail and
from being dirt poor for a long period
of time as director baslerman told
deadline he's trying to mend his life
constantly trying to be liked and
getting people to like each other and
ultimately that's going to end in
self-destruction Lerman spent a lot of
time researching Elvis as a person to
make his movie more authentic even if it
was uncomfortable as the Director told
deadline there were things that were
going to be difficult for Elvis's family
to see about Elvis but they were also
going to see the humanity and true
spirituality of him which was the most
important thing
as well as portraying the real Elvis
bazlerman Wanted the movie to be a
political commentary speaking to GQ
about the film he explained it's
actually about America in the 50s 60s
and 70s he's at the center of culture
for The Good the Bad and the Ugly and
you can't talk about America in that
period without talking about race and so
many other things the film
contextualized as Elvis's role in so
many historical moments such as his
reaction to Martin Luther King Jr's
death additionally Tom hanks's character
Colonel Tom Parker is an obvious
commentary on Greed and corruption with
Lerman telling deadline the colonel
represents the great cell in America and
this therefore made it about America the
sale of the soul the artist and the
ringmaster
becoming Elvis Presley is no easy task
along with studying the king's music and
speech patterns Austin Butler had to put
in the work to physically transform into
the Rock and Roll legend Butler worked
with a strength trainer who was
instrumental in teaching him how to move
his body properly for the role the
training went on for months but once it
came time for filming Butler had to
spend his days in costume this meant
getting Elvis's makeup and hair exactly
right a transformation alone that took
approximately four and a half hours to
complete in addition to dying his hair
Butler went through six wigs while
filming the feature in addition the
actor needed different Prosthetics to
play the music legend at different ages
as the film's hair and makeup designer
told pop sugar we did fewer Prosthetics
on his face for when he was younger to
just keep him fresher and a bit more
round-faced and we added jaw Prosthetics
when he got older to harden his jawline
a little bit and make it more pronounced
baslerman knew that Austin Butler was
the perfect choice to play Elvis however
Elvis's real-life ex-wife Priscilla
Presley took a bit more convincing as
Lerman admitted to deadline she got a
little bit vocal about her doubts she
said I don't know this film could be
crazy and how can this skinny kid play
Elvis however after watching the film at
the Cannes Film Festival Priscilla was
completely moved she praised Butler's
performance in a private letter to
Lerman which she shared with deadlines
saying my whole life I've had to put up
with people impersonating my husband and
I don't know how that boy did it but
every move every wink if my husband was
here he'd say ah damn you are me
in Elvis baslerman weaves a tangled web
of relationships but in December 2022 he
told deadline I've just realized the
true love story of Elvis and the way it
fits into the uvra is between the
audience and Elvis but the more you get
the less love you actually feel it's a
destructive love of course the depth of
this addictive love is wholly apparent
to viewers of the film and to Tom
hanks's character who narrates Elvis in
one scene Colonel Parker even points out
how Elvis's love for Priscilla is
nothing compared to the love he feels
from the audience thus the movie ends
with Colonel Parker claiming that's
ultimately what killed the Superstar
Austin Butler dedicated years of his
life to learning everything he could
about the king of rock and roll that
period of time was intense both mentally
and physically so it's not surprising
that it changed him speaking to deadline
Butler revealed it's allowed me to
really appreciate the things that I'm
now getting to experience in my life
even just being with my family or
anything like that because there's a lot
of loneliness in Elvis's Life playing
the King has also had an impact on
Butler's career as the New York Post
wrote in a review of the movie he grabs
Us by the caller and never lets go being
so good as Elvis will either explode his
career or shove it into a mouse hole
since Elvis came out Butler has already
proven that his star is most definitely
on the rise he has two feature films
coming out in 2023 including Dune part
2. speaking to GQ director baz luhrmann
compared Butler's continuing success to
Leonardo DiCaprio's After Romeo and
Juliet so while Elvis may have left the
building
Butler is here to stay
[Music]